Whoa.
So many people.
Did you see Jessica's talk about comics?
Did you like it?
Yeah.
I like comics as well.
And a lot of cartoons.
They are company for me for almost my entire
life.
When I was a kid, I was sitting at the TV
every Sunday morning and watching cartoons
for hours.
My parents didn't like it, but I loved the
cartoons.
Later on, when I went to school, I started
drawing little characters in my math books
in the corner.
And every time you flip the page your characters
came to life.
It was really amazing.
So, my name is Martin.
I'm a principal project engineer.
I organize a conference based around Angular.
I later on used my math books for the original
purpose and studied math.
I love math and the possibilities.
I and love cats.
That's probably the reason why all over the
Internet my cat's face is my avatar for Twitter,
GitHub, everything.
And my cat's nickname, Chaos Monster became
my Twitter handle.
If you see a cat like this, it's probably
me.
I started as a backend developer.
And at some time in the last ten years I switched
to the frontend and became a JavaScript developer.
I did that because I was passionate about
the UX possibilities that you can have.
All the user interaction is most possible
in the browser when AngularJS 1.0.7 came out
years ago.
And I was like, yes!
I want to do everything in the browser because
I want to be close to the user.
I want to have interaction with them.
But I was really, really afraid of animations.
Every time my product owner came to me and
said something like, hey, can you move that
from the left to the right?
I was like, don't you think it would be better
if it suddenly pops up on the right side of
the screen!
It's way better, it's way better and I don't
have to do animations.
The time passed by and I watched documentation
by Studio Ghibli, creating the moving castle.
And this was about how they made walking animations
a smooth and natural experience for everyone.
And I was like, all the time I learned from
different domains from other professions.
Why don't I look at cartoons and can see what
I can learn about animations from watching
cartoons and learning how they do it?
So, if you do a little bit of research in
field, you are not able to get around this
book, called the illusion of life.
It's by Frank Thomas and Ollie Johnson.
Both are animators at Disney.
And in the '80s when they released that book,
they boiled down all the knowledge that Disney
acquired in the last not 50 decades five decades.
They did the amazing animation movies to 12
principles of animation.
And I thought to myself, after read them,
they are really amazing.
I have a lot that I learned from that and
boiled it down to the eight principles of
web animation.
Starting with squash and stretch.
If you think about a ball, a tennis ball,
for example.
And if you think how a tennis ball would behave
if you throw it on the floor and how it would
bounce back into the air.
You think about it, it wouldn't really change
its form, its shape.
It would look something like this.
But that doesn't feel really good.
Because you can't feel the speed of the ball.
You can't feel the impact of the ball on the
floor and you can't feel how the ball falls
jumps back into the air.
So, what you can do instead is doing stretch
and squash.
You use stretch to show speed.
To show how the ball gets accelerated.
And you use squash to show how the ball gets
pulled and pushed into the floor.
And how the energy goes back into speed afterwards.
And you cannot only use that to create a ball
that bounces off a floor, but you can also
use it to create a feeling for material.
This box that is created with key frames in
CSS feels really squashy.
It feels like bouncy.
It gets adjectives.
It's not just a box.
So, you have to keep a few things in mind
when you do that.
For example, you have to think about the volume.
The volume of the object should not change
because your brain recognizes if you're just
changing the volume of the object by squashing
or stretching it.
And it feels really off if you do that.
And you can use squash and stretch to give
objects weight and a feeling of speed.
And also, to give them material.
The feeling on how the material works.
The second principle is anticipation.
If you look at this stick figure, you would
think, okay, what happens next?
You would not expect it to just fly off in
the air like this.
It doesn't feel right, right?
What you actually want to do is you want it
to bend the knees and then go up.
Because with that, you give the view of this
animation, the feeling that something will
happen.
The user can anticipate what happens next.
If I'm going down and I'm jumping up, you
will expect me to jump up because you've seen
me going to the floor and you expect something
to happen here.
And you can use the same in the browser when
you do some animations before you do a bigger
animation.
Before you show that you can drag and drop
it.
Also, really important what I did not do here,
but what can be really important for anticipation
is the timing.
So, if you slowly start winding up before
you do a really fast throw of a ball, this
is also important.
Not only the winding up.
But also, the speed of how I do it.
The third principle is staging.
Frank and Ollie talked said it's like that.
If you have a presentation of an idea, it
should be completely and unmistakably clear
what you want to do.
Don't irritate your user or viewer by pointing
them in a certain direction and then doing
something totally different.
Look at the stage and all those arrows.
I focus you on one point of the screen.
Doesn't have to be the center of the screen
but focus your view on one point of the screen
and you expect something to happen here like
a character appearing like a magician.
And use that technique wherever you do it.
If it's on the left or on the right, just
use it to make it clear for the user where
something will appear, or something will happen.
The same goes for when we are in the western
culture.
We expect something that comes from the left
to the right to appear on stage.
If it goes from the center to the right, we
think it disappears from stage and you would
drop it down to the bottom of the stage.
You think it will never come back.
Keep those things in mind because they are
part of staging.
When you look at this green diff.
And I want you to focus on that diff.
Now I told you to focus on the diff.
Imagine you're a user and you're in a browser
and I want you as a developer to focus on
the diff.
What I can do is I can make the background
opaque and do a little bit of animation to
focus on the green diff.
Maybe it's a greet button.
Maybe I want you to save that form because
otherwise all your data will be gone.
Number four.
I have a little bit of a problem with that
because in animation this is a really, really
important thing to do.
But I wasn't sure how to translate it to the
web browser.
Let's go a little bit back.
If you have a motion in a movie or an anime,
you have a lot of pictures and those pictures
slightly change from frame to frame.
Normally we talk about 12 to 24 frames per
second.
If you're a gamer, you want to run on 60 frames
per second.
Meaning you want to have so many images that
slightly differentiate to each other in each
second.
And back in the days, in the 1980s and before
that, before this was a thing, all of those
frames, all of those images, had to be drawn
by hand.
So, people were sitting there and drawing
the same image over and over again and just
slightly make a change to the previous one.
And here comes the technique of straight ahead.
If you just change the image just slightly
without any concept or any story about it,
you just create something that is randomly
moving like fire or rain or explosions.
This is a really great technique to do that.
But if you want to tell a story, you need
a concept, a story board behind that.
And for that you think about, what is my first
pose?
And then you think about will be my last pose?
And you think about, what poses are in between
those two poses that are important for me
to show my audience?
So, the audience gets an understanding of
the movement we want to have.
And then you create those key frames and afterwards
you just add more and more frames by using
the straight-ahead technique.
And then at the end you have a movement.
And with CSS we have CSS Transform, we have
scale, rotate, you name it.
And we also have CSS keyframes.
And this is where my mind just popped.
I have those poses.
Those are key frames.
They are frames that are really important
for how the animation would work.
Same goes for web animation API.
And if you look at keyframes, and this is
no change to how web animations work with
the web animation API, you create your initial
pose you create your final pose, and if you
want to, you create a few poses in between
that are important to tell the story of how
your object moves and then you let the browser
just fill in all the other thousands of frames
that you might want to have.
The fifth principle of animation frames is
overlapping action.
If I have the pod and tell you I'm moving
from the right to the left.
You would imagine the flower pod to move and
you would imagine the flower to move.
Follow through and overlapping means that
you can drag secondary animations like the
flower.
Because the flower takes a little bit longer
than the flowerpot until it realizes that
something is moving.
And it takes a little bit longer to that's
just physics to realize that it stopped.
And this is called follow through and overlapping
action.
And if you look at the browser, I found this
great article.
Get the slides afterwards and I highly recommend
to read that article.
That mentions how to fix drag and drop by
using a little bit of math.
You see why I was into that article.
And what they do is they use the mouse movement
speed and translate it into the tilde of the
dragged object.
The faster the mouse moves, the higher the
angle of the object, the tildes.
And if the mouse moves slowly, the tilde goes
back to a horizontal stage.
And this makes all your drag and drop animations
feel way more natural.
Way more like I want to drag and drop everything
here because it's awesome.
Slow in and slow out.
I read that principle and I was like, yes.
I totally understand it.
I know how this will work in the browser.
Just for you to present how it works, slow
in and slow out means if I'm starting running
over there, I won't start with full speed.
And if I'm stopping at end of the stage, I
won't stop at full speed.
I will slow down.
This is a natural movement.
I will show it to you just for the sake that
you see it.
[ Laughter ]
I'm walking very fast.
I'm slowing down.
And back.
I start fast, slowing down.
Yeah.
I did my sport for today.
[ Applause ]
I would never imagine that someone claps when
I'm running.
And we have the same thing in the browser.
We call them easing functions.
We call them busy functions.
If you have an ease in and ease out function
on your animation, it comes to it at a faster
speed and slows down before it's at its final
stage.
And if you do a linear transformation, it
will have the same speed from the beginning
until the end.
And this feels really mechanical.
Not natural like in and out.
And mechanical is something that we really
don't have that often.
Even a car that is mechanical would slowly
start.
Only things like bullets would be really fast
from the beginning.
Secondary actions.
This is about how your main action, your main
animation, needs sometimes support so you
can tell a story.
And for that you need a concept.
And, for example, if I'm walking over that
side of the stage, my arms are really stiff.
And I'm walking and you see the walking animation.
Imagine animation.
And it feels really stiff and really unnatural.
So, what I actually do when I walk and probably
all of you if you're walking, you move your
upper body.
You move your arms.
Okay.
I'm a little over accelerating now.
But you move your body with that.
And the movement of the arms and the shoulders
are the secondary action and they support
the main animation, meaning the walking animation.
I found this really, really, really awesome
CSS animation by Andrew Wong.
And I don't want you to focus on the walking
animation.
I want you to focus on the secondary animations
here.
Meaning the clouds in the back, the signs
inform back.
They are secondary animations that help to
give the animation depth.
That help to give your relation to how fast
this object is moving.
And this helps you to understand the main
animation.
So, secondary animations are really, really
good when it comes to how to improve your
main animation.
And with that I'm coming to the eighth principle
called appealing.
Frank and Ollie just said, "Make your animations
appeal.
Make the viewer feel like I love this character.
I totally dig this character, how it works
and moves."
And I want to make that my conclusion as well.
So, here's my conclusion of looking at the
12 principles of animation by Frank and Ollie.
And how to translate them to the web.
First, use animations to improve your user
experience.
Because motion can tell a story.
And to tell a story, you need a storybook.
Make yourself comfortable with the idea to
think about, where does my animation start?
What is in between of my animation?
And where does my animation stop?
Make this concept, not only for one animation,
but for the entirety of your website.
Think about how all the animations can work
together.
And please, don't overdo your animations because
if you do too much, and it doesn't feel really
right.
And last but not least, have fun.
Have fun with doing animations because animations
are great.
And don't be afraid as I was.
Because there's so much content about how
to do animations.
Look at 12 principles of animations and learn
from over a century of animations on how to
really do great animations.
Thank you for listening to me.
And thanks, JSConf EU, for giving me the opportunity
to talk to you about animations.